goats in a bad way for week 10 chris you
get the first pick well i think i'm
going to go with
the 49er special teams that's going to
be my goats in a bad i know that's a bad
one and everything like that like it's
not a specific player but man that was
such a
debacle in what they did in this
football game i mean really it was there
to be had for them to steal the game in
new orleans there the other day two
dropped punts and then let up a huge
kick return to give the ford the saints
a short field so they had three scoring
drives because the 49ers special teams
was you know poor that was an issue it
was a day where their defense had it
going a little bit and had a feel for
this saints offense but because of those
issues you know it really put the 49ers
out of the football game and meta put
them out of the out of reach for the
season it might be over in night night
time now in san francisco
you know how there's a strategy to this
process where you you you want to take a
good one and then maybe you can sandbag
because you know you can still get it in
round three yeah you know that right we
could have done a 10-round draft we
could have done a 20-round draft and we
wouldn't have got the 49ers special
teams on my ledger so you you you you
shot your shot and uh thank you for
leaving who i think is the biggest go to
the week on the board and that's chase
young the washington pass rusher who had
that ridiculous stupid
middle school mistake i remember doing
that playing grade school football
hitting the quarterback after the ball
was out and drawing a penalty st it's
like why do you do that actually i did
it was that before the hiccups or after
them
that was before that okay that was
before the broken ribs no what i did one
time playing grade school football the
punter punt of the ball and i just
decked him and it's like oh yeah i know
that's a penalty i watch football on tv
but i couldn't help myself it's not a
rookie mistake it's and that's what
chase young called it rookie no it's an
idiotic move because the same rules
apply in college after the quarterback
throws the ball you can't knock him on
his ass
and i it's it just was stupid because it
it allowed the lions to get the field
goal that that won the game so uh just
ridiculous from chase young no excuse
for it yeah no there there is no excuse
for it he's played enough games this
year to know what that you know what the
jurisdiction is as far as how many steps
you're allowed there to hit the
quarterback and all that uh so that that
was that was inexcusable um it was a
good pick it wasn't as good as my 49er
special teams one sure it wasn't i'm
sure it wasn't drew locke will be my
next one on this list um
man
drew lock's got to dial it back you know
i know vic fangio and company kind of
made a a uh you know a statement on
monday saying he's our guy and we just
got to push through this and all those
type of things listen he has talent and
he makes plays and i love the way he
looks but
he's really got to start to play the
position a little more true to form this
ain't college football anymore and we're
just looking for 20 and 30-yard cool
highlight plays there's it's too
aggressive it's too oh i'm gonna smash
this ball into a tight window and it's
really hurting their chances as a
football team to win games he's got to
learn how to play the position a little
bit better and take care of the football
and i'm not one to usually say that but
it's just getting a little reckless with
him
you know i i was going to be in that
same general vicinity let me just make
this observation instead of making this
guy one of the goats because i was on
wscr the score in chicago yesterday and
the issue of the broncos came up because
they have an affinity for vic fangio
there he was the bears defensive
coordinator is he in trouble right i
mean at what point do you
do you stop focusing on
the quarterbacks who are being selected
and the coaches are being hired and go
one level higher and say maybe
there's an issue with the guy
who's making these decisions i hear you
if you're firing your coach after every
couple years if you're getting rid of
your quarterback after every couple
years at some point it lands on john
elway and he's in a great spot because
there's nobody there to fire him yeah
but at some point the scrutiny's got to
land on john elway it's only fair you
get the praise when it goes well and if
you're firing coach after coach and and
swinging and missing on quarterback
after quarterback at some point it's on
you as the gm of the team all right next
one for me okay go doug peterson he's
going to take the blame of what happened
against the giants he gets the blame we
said this yesterday he's the andy reid
protege who should be able to get the
most out of two weeks to get ready for
anyone and it was the giants for crying
out loud and you're trying to put a
hammer lock on first place in the nfc
east and your team was woefully
unprepared to beat the giants if you
want the blame it makes our job easy you
can't get mad at us we played the sound
he's blaming himself
fine doug you're one of the goats of the
week yeah i i hear that i mean he i was
i had the eagles written down i wasn't
sure where i was gonna go with that if i
was gonna make doug peterson carson
wentz i don't know
either way to go what were they o for
nine on third down on sunday was it o
for nine or was it worse than that i
gotta double check oh for nine i don't
know how that happens i really don't
with doug peterson and carson wentz
against the new york giants without a
great pass rusher and anything like that
0 for 9 like how all right i'm going to
go with russell wilson i think it's the
next one that jumps out to me here you
know
again hey russell's the man i mean
there's no doubt we know that and we
talk about him like he's the man we
praise him just about as more than
anybody on tv
uh but hey when you are the man we
expect you to be the man on a weekly
basis and right now hey it's two weeks
in a row you know
he's not totally the man and last week
you know especially in a game where
it wasn't just a shootout and we're
gonna let it fly everywhere it was a
little bit of a you know struggle there
at 17 to 10 that interception he throws
in the back left corner that was a huge
moment in the football game it was
really the moment seattle had the chance
to take back momentum that they had not
had up to that point so between that and
then the interception in the second half
they were both really crucial and hurt
the seattle seahawks chances of winning
the game
my last one would be bill's partner cory
bejorquez if his 12-yard punt in that
game against the cardinals it happened
at a more critical moment in the game
but it was early enough before the
ending and the hail murray that wiped it
all clean i'm gonna go bill laser hey
what are you doing what are you doing
four three and outs in the second half
and i know matt and aggie kind of thrust
that duty on to him but that's what you
want to do as an offensive coordinator
you want to call plays or you're not
really the offensive coordinator it
didn't coordinate a very good offense on
monday night that was bad as bad as it's
gotten for the bears all year and
there's no indication it's going to get
any better
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports